Speaker 1: Former Democratic Senator Al Franken
appeared on CNN alongside Republican strategist
Alice Stewart to talk about the Supreme Court's
decision to overturn Roe v Wade and the political
orientation of the court. And I have not seen
anything like this in a very long time. Al Franken
turned Alice Stewart into a sputtering mess over
the issue of Republicans holding up nominations,
including that of Merrick Garland. And it is it's
truly a pleasure to watch. And, you know, one of
the things we've been talking about on the show
is Democrats need to be on the offensive. Gavin
Newsom said Democrats need to be ruthless and I
completely agree. We need more like this because
when you actually don't allow them to squirm away
from direct questions, like, when else was this
strategy used to deny nominees a hearing other
than for Merrick Garland? Alice Stewart completely
implodes. This is so well done. Take a look.
Speaker 4: A week before the election. That had
destroyed the legitimacy of the court. Alice,
what do you think? Chief Justice Roberts Sort of.
I mean, he sort of ignored some of what Al is
talking about there, and that there is, I mean,
a tremendous amount of controversy
as to how this court got tilted
in the direction of the far right.
Speaker 3: Just to throw a little
accuracy and some of what Al said there. Look, the
the Merrick Garland was held up because we had a
divided government. We had a Democrat in the White
House and we had Republicans in control of it.
Speaker 4: But that's not what McConnell said.
Speaker 3: But but that's the way that
historically this has been when you're in close to
an election year and you have divided government.
Speaker 4: The way it's done.
Speaker 3: Yes. And when you have
divided government, there typically is.
Speaker 1: Now you'll actually see the
moment she starts sputtering.
Speaker 4: Inclination to tell
me what has happened before.
Speaker 3: When you had me. When I was
throwing up when you're well. Merrick
Garland is certainly one when there's a
divided government before moving forward.
They're moving. They're not moving forward.
Speaker 4: Tell me why this happened before.
Speaker 3: Al, I'm telling you,
this is what the. But tell.
Speaker 4: Me what had happened.
Speaker 3: Before. I can't believe.
Speaker 4: It's happened historically.
Tell me when it happened before.
Speaker 3: Look, this is the way
that the Republicans. When. Like,
I can't give you an exact example of when
this happened, but you know why? You can tell.
Speaker 4: You. Because it hadn't happened before.
Speaker 3: Look,
the basis for not appointing him was because
of that specific reason. But no, it wasn't.
Speaker 4: And McConnell's explicitly
said that it was the, quote, Biden rule,
and he called it a little piece of a speech that
Biden had given in June of 88. And he Biden said
they wouldn't take up if they weren't consulted.
And if this is about someone resigning in June
after a term of the court, which is very different
than someone dying, Scalia died in February.
And you saw you guys, if you can find the
tape, you can find Lindsey Graham saying,
I keep the tape. We will not take
up a judge if someone dies as
a nominee, if someone dies in an election year
in the next in the next election. This is total
hypocrisy. And you actually I'm surprised that
you're claiming this and you can't come up with
an example because there is none.
Speaker 3: Look, the to get back
to the point of no.
Speaker 1: But this is.
Speaker 4: The. No, this is the point.
Speaker 2:
This is the point. That's exactly right.
Speaker 3: We're talking about Kamala
Harris and her calling.
Speaker 1: Kamala.
Speaker 3: The current Supreme
Court justices, activist justices,
because she doesn't like the outcome of their
ruling and when they're made their decision.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, the point here
is, how did this court even become what it is?
I think that to some degree, this is what
Democrats need to do every time Republicans lie.
Call them out, shame them, continue to expose
that they are lying now. Why was that? Why did
this even happen? You have to understand, right?
It's because Jim Acosta allowed it to happen
in many other settings. The anchor or the
interviewer will will prevent this from happening,
either for reasons of time and formatting
or because they want to bail out one side.
Jim Acosta, at any point could have jumped in
and saved Alice Stewart. She didn't deserve to
be saved. And it's a good thing that Jim Acosta
didn't. She was lying. And the other person she's
arguing against called her out for her lies. And
it was silly to think that you were going to be
able to get away with that with someone like Al
Franken. Al Franken identified the silly game and
he called it out. Now, this is representative of a
bigger issue with the Republican Party right now.
They have zero integrity in politics. If there
is no precedent or a rule that says you can't
do something, they will do it. And then they will
say, that's the precedent. I mean, think of the.
I want to stop short of calling it evil genius,
because it's it's these things aren't really that
smart. They work because the system tolerates
them and the people tolerate them. And maybe,
maybe we shouldn't. But the the idea here
is she says, okay, well, we did this thing
with Merrick Garland and Al Franken says, but
what's the precedent for that? And she says,
Well, it happened with Garland, right? No, but
what's the precedent? At that point, what was
the precedent? We did it with Garland. No, but
that Garland can't be the precedent for Garland.
It's all so stupid and it's such a base and
fundamentally vapid sort of framing of the debate.
But when they're allowed to get away with it, of
course they're going to continue doing it. And,
you know, to go back to the Al Franken
thing, we've talked about this before.
Al Franken did engage in a very distasteful
joke. You know, this photograph that that
led to his eventual resignation from the from the
Senate. I do think Democrats were a little quick
in order to show their lack of hypocrisy in
demanding that Franken resign when compared
to so many other things that have
happened for which no one has resigned.
It was so minor. And we've talked to Democrats who
say, yeah, it was it was actually a little bit.
Jumping the gun on demanding Franken resign just
to show how non hypocritical we are. Franken
is really good at this and absolutely
humiliating there for Alice Stewart.